Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Christian
from Edmonton?
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
Hello.
Thanks for taking my call.
Pleasure.
I had a question about election systems.
OK, so of course I'm here in Canada, but I'm
aware that you guys have the popular vote
interstate compact attempting to, you know,
change the way you guys do your electoral
system.
Yes, I understand it needs, you know, like
a bit under one hundred more electoral seats
in order to become active.
But here, especially in Alberta, but in Canada
as a whole, too, we do have a problem with
gerrymandering, just like you guys in the
states as an example from our last election
in 2021.
The NDP is there kind of like the Progressive
Party here?
They received three million votes, which is
17 percent, and they got twenty five seats.
But the Bloc Quebecois, which only is in Quebec,
they don't run in any other province.
Yes, they got one point three million, which
is seven point six percent, and they got thirty
two.
So.
And it's more than just a population thing.
And so when the Trudeau government first came
into power in 2015, they ran on personal representation.
But I imagine they ran the numbers if we had
something like Germany or Japan and quickly
realized they'd lose a ton of power, so they
abandoned it.
Do you think making a change to the proportional
system or a popular vote interstate compact
would fix gerrymandering?
Or do you think it's more systemic than that?
Speaker 1: Are you saying in the United States?
Speaker 3: Yeah, in the US or if we in Canada,
we change to a correctional system.
Speaker 1: There's different.
These are two different things that are so
I can only speak to the United States and
the United States.
There's two different things going on.
The national popular vote Interstate Compact
is a way to use a national popular vote to
choose the president without having to make
a constitutional change, which is states just
agree.
We will give our votes to whoever wins the
popular vote.
So that gets us out of the Electoral College.
That's one thing separately to deal with gerrymandering,
which is within states in the U.S. setting
up either.
I mean, at this point, computers can fairly
draw district maps or setting up a nonpartisan,
you know, a district redistricting committee
that would solve Partizan gerrymandering within
states.
And it's totally separate from the national
popular vote interstate compact to different
things to different problems they would solve.
Speaker 3: OK, so like if the interstate compact
came into effect because enough states were
able to just go on proportional rate, the
the states that still gerrymander, like the
southern states that do it really bad, they
would still do that.
It just wouldn't matter.
Speaker 1: It the gerrymandering has nothing
to do with the presidential.
OK, so the what the gerrymandering is for
district seats within states like, what is
the what is the what is the map of AOC district?
Come on, can at least separate from how we
select the president?
All right, my friend.
Thank you for the call.
Very important issue that is going to do it
for calls today.
I apologize if I didn't get to you, but I
will try to do better next time.